one slip of the hand and this
100-year-old first edition book could be
ruined
forever that's why restoring a book like
this takes immense patience and
precision I used to take the books apart
a little bit in front of my clients
until I said their faces would just be
like they don't need to know nobody
needs to know what I'm doing so but you
guys get to know meet Sophia Bogle book
restorer educator and author who has
dedicated her life to preserving our
stories I have probably restored
thousands of books I don't actually know
the
number some of the most important things
in book restoration some of the steps
involved are deconstruction opening the
spine scraping the old spine doing color
matching for the text block there's page
washing if needed page repair and then
reconstructing the book not every book
is the same it's one of the main reasons
that makes this such a difficult
specialty to become really good at here
I have the first edition of The Lost
Princess of Oz and it's in terrible
shape very dirty on the front cover the
spine is breaking pages are torn up so
normally a restoration like this could
take between 8 and 12 hours one of the
first things is to separate the text
block from the cover
there are other book repair knives out
there this one I designed to be like a
fingertip it does sometimes feel like
book surgery sometimes more than others
especially those tight joint tight back
leather books those are nerve-wracking
talk about surgery you have to cut into
the leather around the little panels dye
the leather and make that match so that
everything is as invisible as possible
having done all that this is the
result some pages need to be washed
other Pages might just need a few
repairs this kind of tear right here is
a beveled or a scarf tear it just means
it has two overlapping areas and those
are the best kind because you can just
put some paste in there so I've got my
rice starch paste literally just going
to paint these two
[Music]
together so now we're going to use the
shadow Tracer a piece of black paper and
then something clear in plastic over it
we're tracing the shape with some water
so that we can tear it
out so now think I'm going to put it on
this side
[Music]
starting to look better there we go so
that's a good start I might actually do
that again to make that thicker but for
now that's that's good and that can just
be trimmed to fit and then that's fitted
in there while a lot of Sophia's work
centers around her desk her Workshop is
full of unique tools for restoration all
right so this is my binder and over here
I've got my old sewing frame which uses
these old-fashioned keys and then over
here I've got kind of the more modern
version this is the Jeff peachy no key
system it's kind of cool have both kinds
this is a job backer and it's pretty old
from the 1800s you put the book in here
and then you squish it and then you can
work on it with a hammer or a saw which
really freaks people out this is the
gold finishing stove and my Apprentice
used to call this the bear trap because
it looks like it could just close up on
your hand at any moment this is
something that you need to do leather
restoration work this was all done by
hand you put the gold on and then you do
the tooling and this is an example of
the the gold leaf I just keep little
scraps of it in here it's really hard to
work with cuz it's so
delicate so here I've got my Quick Print
stamping machine and I've got a lot of
weird little do daddy things that you
can stamp with as well as a lot of fonts
and this is a whole another thing where
anything you can put into a black and
white design you can have made into a
diee you know here's Toto this is how it
operates you put your little device in
here bring it back
down and you squish it the impression
that it makes is called the kiss which I
just love let's see how that turned out
so then over here is my nipping press
these were originally made to make
copies these days everybody who's a book
binder would want one of these because
you can put your book in here and press
it and it works really
well sometimes in the restoration
process Pages themselves need to be
removed from the book and washed some of
them are very dirty this one has some
blue ink on it I'm going to test before
we begin and the way to do that is to
take cotton swab get that wet you put a
drop of water and you just stare at
it I can see that's already starting to
go one of the things that we do to help
keep the pages together is we have this
Holly Tex which is the spun polyester
paper and I'm just trying to submerge
it it's like it's taking a little bath I
should get little floaty duck or
something then you can take just a clean
brush so that's basically
it this snack for invisible Artistry has
been years in the learning and part of a
Lifetime Love of literature I was at the
University of Minnesota getting my
English degree I got a student job at
the library binder it was quite the
transformational experience I knew I
wanted to do something with books and I
walked in here and I discovered that
books were taken apart and put back
together and there was one person over
in the corner throwing books into
buckets of water and sewing and you know
all the beautiful things and I was like
oh that's the job I want Sophia's been
doing that job for over 30 years saving
history one book at a time what I want
to do is I want to get at this cover
spine liner by cutting here getting that
open and same thing over
here and then I can start to remove this
old paper which is fairly acidic when
it's more acidic it falls apart
quicker and just clean up the last
little you know bit of that
section restoring the book's spine is an
important step in the process but some
spines POS particularly unique
challenges so this one was truly one of
the most difficult and for such a
special unique book literally one of
these books was made in the world the
original spine was just gone and they
had restored it with this suede so my
challenge was removing this oh it took
so long with a a knife and just scraping
really carefully and just trying to get
that off of there and it came out like
this I mean I I get chills really
because this is Frank bomb's copy for
his mother and there's a wonderful
inscription on the first page so it's
just really fun to be part of that story
too regardless of what steps are
required to return a book to its former
glory the final step is always putting
the book back together or recasing I've
got the hinge that will be tucked in
there I'm actually noticing right now
that the Japanese tissue that I put on
there is extending too far and I have
two options I can lift this up further
or I can tear some of this off and I'm
going to go for the tear some of this
off
version and just get some of
that the edge of the mle makes a nice
Edge to tear it against so super easy
but meanwhile this is the most fun part
I don't think I've even told you about
this you can write things on the spine
of the book this book
restored by
Sophia September 2023 and then my
signatures I always put three dots on I
do love the fact that there's the story
in the book there's a story of the
restoration of the book there's the
story of who has owned the book and now
I'm just in there just a little bit more
I'm taking the the
PVA and you just don't want any glue on
the spine the spine needs to not be
attached to the other spine um because
this is all going
to get tucked in now it's getting there
and I'm just going to go ahead and put
this in to protect it and now it needs
to go up in the Press it's really
important that the book goes in square
and that the pin of this is over the
area that you need it to be over there
we go so I'm going to leave this in here
overnight by tomorrow it'll be finished
and ready to go home no matter how many
books she's restored Sophia takes the
work of book restoration as a vital
responsibility I'm preserving cultural
history it's really important so many
books are being thrown away I want more
people to collect books to think about
that like what can you collect what can
you put on your shelves and take care of
and take stewardship of so that they'll
make it to the next
Generations